you're right instead of treating eyes
ears and skin as separate sensory
systems with fundamentally different
modalities we might understand them as
overlapping aspects of the same universe
coupled at the same Temple resolution
and almost Inseparable from a single
share resonant model instead of treating
mental representations as fully isolated
between Minds The representations of
physically adjacent Observers
might directly interact and produce
causal effects through the coordination
of the perception and behavior of world
modeling Observers
so the modalities the distinction
between modalities throw that away the
distinction between the individuals
let's throw that away
so what does this interaction
representations look like
when you think about how you represent
the interaction of us in this room yeah
at some level you can the modalities are
quite distinct they're not completely
distinct but you can see this is Vision
you can close your eyes and then you
don't see a lot anymore but you still
imagine how my mouth is moving when you
hear something and you know that it's
very close to uh the sound that you can
just open your eyes and you get back
into the street merge space and we also
have these experiments where we notice
that the vein which my lips are moving
are affecting how you hear the sound and
also vice versa the sounds that you're
hearing have an influence on how you
interpret some of the visual features
and so this modalities are not separate
in your mind they do are merged at some
fundamental level where you are
interpreting the entire scene that you
are in and your own interactions in the
scene also not completely separate from
the interactions of the other individual
in the scene but there is some resonance
that is going on where we also have a
degree of shared mental representations
and shared empathy due to being in the
same space and having Vibes between each
other Vibes so the question though is
How Deeply interbined is this
multi-modality multi-agent system
like how I mean this is going to the
telepathy question without the
meaning of the word telepathy
it's like how
like what's going on here in this room
right now so this telepathy would work
how could it work yeah right so imagine
that um all the cells in your body are
sending signals in a similar way as
neurons are doing right just by touching
the other cells and sending chemicals to
them the other cells interpreting them
learning how to react to them and they
learn how to approximate functions in
this way and compute behavior for the
organisms and this is something that is
open to plants as well all right so
plants probably have software running on
them that is controlling how the plant
is working in a similar way as you have
a mind that is controlling how you are
behaving in the world and this Spirit of
plants which is something that has been
very well described by our ancestors and
they found this quite normal but uh for
some reason since the enlightenment we
are treating this notion that there are
spirits in nature and there are plenty
of spirits as a Superstition and I think
we probably have to ReDiscover that that
plants have software running on them and
we already did right you notice that
there is a control system in the plant
that connects every part of the plant to
every other part of the plant and
produces coherent behavior in the plant
that is of course much much slower than
the coherent behavior in an animal like
us that has the nervous system that
where everything is synchronized much
much faster by the neurons but what you
also notice is that if a plant is
sitting next to another plant like you
have a very old tree and this tree is
building some kind of information
Highway along itself so it can send
information from its leaves to its roots
and from some part of the root to
another part of the woods and there is
the fungus living next to the tree the
fungus can probably piggyback on the
communication between the cells of the
tree and send its own signals to the
tree and vice versa the tree might be
able to send informations of the fungus
because after all how would they build a
viable firewall if that other organism
is sitting next to them all the time and
it's never moving away and so they will
have to get along and over a long enough
time frame the networks of roots in the
forest and all the plant other plants
that are there and the fungi that are
there might be forming something like a
biological internet
but the the question there is do they
have to be touching is biology at a
distance possible
of course you can use any kind of
physical signal you can use sounds you
can use electromagnetic waves that are
integrated over many cells it's
conceivable that across distances there
are many kinds of information Pathways
but also uh our planetary surface is
pretty full of organisms full of cells
so everything is touching everything
else yeah and it's been doing this for
um many millions and even billions of
years so there was enough time for
information processing networks to form
and if you think about how a mind is
self-organizing it basically it needs to
in some sense reward these cells for
computing the mind for building
the necessary Dynamics between the cells
that allow the mind to stabilize itself
and remain on there but if you look at
these spirits of plants that are growing
very close to each other in the forest
it might be almost growing into each
other these Spirits might be able even
to move to some degree in order to
become were dislocated and shift around
in in that ecosystem right and so if you
think about what the mind is it's a
bunch of activation waves that form
coherent patterns and process
information in in a way that are
colonizing an environment well enough to
allow the continuous sustenance of the
Mind The Continuous stability and
self-stabilization of the Mind
um then it's conceivable that we can
link into this biological internet not
necessarily at the speed of our nervous
system but maybe at the speed of our
body and make some kind of subconscious
connection to the world where we use our
body as an antenna into biological
information processing now now these
ideas are completely speculative I don't
know if any of that is true but if that
was true and if you want to explain
telepathy I think it's much more likely
that such a data telepathy could be
explained using such mechanisms rather
than an uh discovered Quantum processes
that would break the standard model of
physics
could they be undiscovered processes
that don't break yeah so I uh if you
think about
um something like an internet in the
forest that is something that is
borderline discovered there are
basically a lot of scientists would
point out that they do observe that
plans are communicating the forwards or
wood networks and send information for
instance warn each other about new pests
entering the forest and and things are
happening like this so basically there
is communication between plants and
fungi that has been observed well it's
been observed but we haven't plugged
into it so it's like if You observe
humans they seem to be communicating
with a smartphone thing but you don't
understand how smartphone works and how
the the mechanism of the internet works
but we're like maybe it's possible to
really understand the the full richness
of the biological internet that connects
us an interesting question is whether
the communication and the Organization
principles of biological information
processing are as complex located is the
technology that we've built
they set out on very different
principles right they simultaneously
works very differently in biological
systems and the entire thing needs to be
stochastic and instead of being fully
deterministic or almost fully
deterministic as our literal computers
are so there is a different base
protocol layer that would emerge over
the biological structure if such a thing
would be happening and again I'm not
saying here that telepathy works and not
saying that that is not who but what I'm
saying is I'm I think I'm open to a
possibility that we see that a few bits
can be traveling long distance between
organisms using biological information
processing in ways that we are not
completely aware of right now and that
are more similar to many of the stories
that were completely normal for our
ancestors